so given that life is a solution to a
chemistry problem
if we re ran Earth a million times how
different would
the results be
if we look at that wheel
how different would be the the Tree of
Life do you think like what's Your Gut
say
my uh mind asks are you imagining if if
you're repeating the planet one million
times are we seeing
um artists things that happened I'm not
talking at the chemical level but at the
environment level did do they happen at
the same time at the same frequency at
the same intensity every time you're
running this tape over and over again
yes you mean like geological stuff yeah
like so is this you're saying those are
important I mean that's that's the fact
that you would ask that question is also
fascinating so that's important this is
the timing the frequency the intensity
of geological yeah so when we run this
imaginary rewind and play experiments in
our minds I want to know whether we are
positioning all the same geologic events
at the same chronological order as well
or whether we are also giving them more
randomness so if the volcano erupted is
happening at the same time if if you
have a our dinosaurs getting wiped off
every time with the same meteorite
that's hitting the same but also like
temperature changes that changes
everything
that's actually I've heard you say
somewhere that one of the things that's
fascinating to you about this whole
process of evolution is that
the the mem the memory the the process
of evolution the all the mechanisms were
invented and developed
despite all the variation geologically
through the hardship that Earth has gone
through that the the biological
Innovations persisted this person yeah
despite that which is which is
interesting you kind of think of the
biological Innovations kind of happening
on their own because we so we uh
actually have a center of exploring this
problem uh we want to understand whether
it's almost like judging a book by its
cover right do you just look at an
environment and then see whatever is
present or scares in that environment
and then think that okay the life form
that will exist in this environment will
obviously have a lot of molybdenum in
its system look at all this bulletin
around here or will it be uh because if
you say that you are now putting the
environment in in
the more Prime driver role right that
you're saying that environment will
determine what biology will or will not
use
um but we've done studies that show that
it's not necessarily the straightforward
that for instance we looked at going
back to nitrogen uh one thing that's
fascinating about the way cells fix
nitrogen uh the ones that can do is that
they also do this through a lot of help
of a lot of metals a lot of Elemental
support really
and
um which geologists use to understand
where did this metabolism even evolved
where at first place so we look at
ancient oceans we try to understand the
elemental composition of ancient oceans
and what we see is that
in some cases the metabolisms even
though they prefer a certain metal or an
element that is in the environment
that metal wasn't abundant in the
environment but still life shows that so
it's not that straightforward as though
whatever you you are you are what you
eat but you don't necessarily eat what
is obvious to you and just because
there's a lot of that food around it
doesn't mean life will ultimately go
there maybe most of the time it will but
it seems like in the case of nitrogen
fixation it didn't and maybe that made
the difference it's so cool that uh
right it's not the Abundant resource
that's going to be the definition of
what kind of life flourishes
so
so it's not it's not a straightforward
thing yes but your sense is that the
different timing of the different
conditions of the environment would
change the way Evolution happens yeah
for instance I mean there I think it's
in the 80s maybe earlier than that the
Stephen J Gold's book Wonderful Life
which changed I think a lot of
scientists life including mine
um he contemplates on this notion of the
tape of Life Of course
I hope people still know what tape is
but I think your listeners will know
what tape is I don't know it's the uh
tape Taiwan tell me about this is it
like a tick tock do can you swipe on it
I am sorry go ahead I apologize
but
rather if life was recorded on or Can Be
Imagined to be recorded on a linear is a
linear chain of events recorded on a
tape and if we were to rewind the step
would be listened to the same song right
so this was and in his proposition I
also thought
um yeah but are we replaying the tape in
the same exact manner or are we meaning
all the geological and environmental
events are they happening at the same
time because then you removed the
randomness from equation a little bit
right you just
removed it because you're assuming
everything will happen at the same time
at the same intensity so that's not two
contingent
um that means that the natural selection
you're thinking is really operating it
more or evolution is operating it more
under more random forces uh then that
can be dictated by the environment so in
our way of understanding or thinking
about rewinding replaying I don't think
we're thinking about the role of the
environment is clearly or don't seem to
be integrated as much
put out I also wonder if it's possible
that the chemistry ultimately defines
the destination
that um
despite all the environmental changes
despite all the randomness
but we are not talking about whether
life will emerge and sustain itself
we're talking about whether life will
emerge and sustain itself in the shape
and form that is similar to what we have
right now so you are chemistry I'm
chemistry we're having this conversation
and your plans are chemistry too they
are also having their own conversation
these plants are fake but yes but don't
want to say that but they they're fake
but do you look at my place of course
that would be fake otherwise they would
die what's wrong with this place it's uh
it's wonderful it's
um we're I'm Alice and this is
Wonderland this this is great this is
great it's just that you know there's
this is a place where robots flourish
and this is that those plants are fake
are you saying that you and I are the
only living organisms well obviously
there are microbes in this room but yeah
yeah we are the only living organisms a
second of getting a dog well you you
know this is not a clean room so you
have microbes here yes many millions yes
so so you and I and all the microbes in
this room your chemical systems that are
operating it in a way that we can
respond and sense and our environments
and whatnot yeah but in if you are
asking if you're going to be here then
you're imagining that another solution
is also possible which is different
then the fundamentals of life because
life will be always life will do its
life thing
I guess it goes all the way back to the
things we're talking about translation
and the stuff you were messing with is
figuring out what is the important stuff
and what isn't
makes you wonder about you know just
like with the Trans uh translation
machinery
with human beings I wonder what's the
important stuff is it important to have
two limbs
is it important to have eyes like it was
obvious that the sensory mechanism of
eyes like sight were to develop how many
times if you're in Earth would the
sensory mechanism of sight develop and
what would it look like would it be one
giant eye
I would be two what's with a symmetry
why are we so damn symmetrical in
response to Steve J Gold's proposition
uh
most people who would who argue that
life is convergent and it will in fact
lead to a few determined outcomes or the
it's not that the outcome is determined
per se but uh it's the pathways are
restricted and the mutational
trajectories that life can act upon uh
are already very limited so that the
final outcomes are a few
and eyes being one of them so
the con the convergence that the eye
level was suggested as an example was
presented as an example of why life may
actually embark on the same solution
over and over again given that many
species evolved it independently from
one another do you think there's any
inkling of Truth there like uh is it
just us humans thinking we're special I
think the those Innovations came again
so far after the uh
the fun stuff yes uh because it's it's
thank you I mean thank you I think we
humans tend to talk about the later
stuff but without the earlier yeah when
we think of earlier there's
and I asked this to my students too I
want them to close their eyes and think
about just nothingness but dust we don't
have trees we don't have plants when we
say an empty place or visually at least
two we're talking about a planet that is
really alien so understanding our own
past is similar to understanding an
alien planet altogether given that it is
a very different planet that did not
have any Oxygen for 2 billion years we
there's nothing that is familiar to us
that we would even think about but when
we think about life that is present in
our past yet here we are so cool that
from that came this like houses and we
are very very we are the super late
arrivals to the party right so this is
definitely not our planets
it's the microbial planets that we live
in but the potential to create us was
always there
I just know that
because we were created
oh
I don't know I what is it you think it's
possible this even for the early stuff
yeah maybe if it's super unlikely yeah
that we just got super oh this is the
planet that got really lucky given the
chemistry
like maybe to create the bacteria is not
so lucky
but to create complex organisms all the
way up to mammals that's super lucky yes
and it may all come down to a few
innovations that happened at the
molecular levels
um that may or may not be inevitable
that's that so all these molecular
tricks may have enabled the the sort of
mere existence of whatever you are able
to Define as familiar to yourself and
you have a hope that science can answer
this these questions to reconstruct
science is answering these questions I
mean it's a we are limited to going uh
back to the beginning in our ways right
so we rely on biology it says
overwritten you're talking about for
four billion year old records that is
ever changing that again makes it
beautiful but also makes it difficult
it's not tractable
geology has
some degree to some degree it has a
record of a more static
Frozen state record that is embedded on
itself on the surface of this planet if
we can find them
and that's the key that most of these
recorded
um
remnants are
if we're lucky we find them they are not
naturally selected
they're they're found they need to be
found for us to read them so we work
with a very handful set of samples
especially when we talk about the Deep
past the
planets with no oxygen when we passed
the great oxidation event threshold that
is about 2.5 billion years so the
earliest life is even harder you are
trying to write to the story of life
based on a handful of rocks and what is
recorded on them